oh my gosh
in a tournament marked by poor
attendance and middling public interest
cameroon's knockout match against
minnows comoros was exactly what the
organizers were looking for
but scenes of pandemonium at cameroon's
biggest venue have shocked fans and
non-fans alike
witnesses say thousands of supporters
were directed to a gate on the southern
side of olembe stadium
some tried to push their way through
and hundreds were caught and crushed in
the middle
the authorities say eight people have
been killed one of whom was a child and
38 others were injured images emerged on
social media of supporters lying
motionless on the ground
just now there were 50 people i saw
nearly 50 people on the ground the
barriers were shut and people were
pushing they were falling on top of each
other and there were babies in there
with a mixture of grief and disbelief
relatives of the dead and injured
gathered at hospitals in the capitol
this woman questioning how such a thing
could possibly happen
the cameroonian president has asked
people to exercise self-discipline
during the tournament while the
organizers have promised an inquiry
in recent days officials have been
offering free tickets and transport as
they try to fill the stadia but
spectators are still subject to covid
related rules and the cues and delays
along with impatient crowds have proven
a volatile mix
john sparks sky news